Speaker 1: Let's go next to Joseph
from Oregon. Joseph, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Thanks for
taking my call. I totally shaded your
I appreciated your coverage of the State of
the Union last night and the other night, and
I just wanted to ask a question kind of about
what kind of the strategy for Dems and what
they do going forward. OK? It sounded like the
speech was vague and understandably optimistic,
but overall sound like it was aimed at
leaning conservatives and centrists.
And maybe without the four things Biden mentioned
with like the opioid crisis eating, having better
mental health, supporting our veterans and ending
cancer. They didn't really sound like there was an
actual plan for those things. And maybe other than
the opioid crisis, I'm not sure if any of those
items on the agenda are really that popular.
So with the midterms coming up, like what do
you think the strategy should be for the Dems to
get a strong swing back in time for the midterms?
Speaker 1: I actually think that it's less about
strategy, but it's about you got to get something
done and I completely agree with you. And one of
my critiques after the State of the Union was,
I think, Joe Biden's rhetoric on the foreign
policy piece, particularly Russia. Ukraine was
strong. I think it ended strong. There were some
good moments in the middle, but the sort of like
listing what was probably like a dozen different
things. I mean, he talked about the four things
you mentioned. He talked about controlling prices
for industries, charging too much, talked about
doing the taxes where the rich and corporations
will pay more. There was all this, this list
of stuff, almost all of which has no path to
happening, certainly in the next year, if at all,
under Joe Biden's presidency. Sadly, I wish it
were different. And the one place I disagree
with you is, I think the whole point of those four
things Biden mentioned was that while they might
not be the issues the audience is most passionate
about, they're sort of like uncontroversial. Like,
who doesn't want to end cancer? Although
some Republicans didn't even clap for that,
which is crazy, but I think it was deliberate to
create some moments where everybody appears to
be on the same page. So rhetorically, I understand
it. Although I agree with you that it's like those
aren't the top issues for most people. I get that.
So I think it was OK. Like I said, I gave it a B.
Speaker 2: Yeah, sorry. And I realized
I meant to say to like, of course,
like beating like everyone wants to end cancer,
like that's a popular thing. I just don't think
like you legislate your way through cancer.
Speaker 1: No, probably not. Probably not.
That's fair. So that's fair. Thank you for taking
my call. My pleasure. Great to hear from you.
Let's take a very quick break. We're not done with
phone calls, so if you still want to talk to me,
don't hang up because we're going to
go right back to the phones in a moment